[Music]
what Oh guys were at the 2019 la
comic-con and for the first time ever we
are doing a JK news we did Jay King news
live several times but the other time we
did it at a convention was at the LA
Auto Show we did that was Steve Aoki
we've done to give you live once before
and that was the Steve Aoki and then
oh yeah that wasn't out because that was
Auto conventions there was another
convention but it wasn't the comic
convention I know what that ale-8
I think what's here too and yeah I was
really really nervous
Steve Aoki's there is an actual light
body those first time I've ever been in
front of people like other people's wait
hold on I feel very stupid right now I'm
sorry okay but there was also no
audience but with a different okay and
I'd even really know if you don't want
to be the feeling weird but exciting
news
we're studies show that Millennials are
finally interested in buying new cars
I'm a big fan yeah here's Rob you like
what are these [ __ ] Asian people do
yeah he did like twelve Shelley seems
retired it seemed like you're like like
Toyota made him do it
okay so cool yeah it didn't count then
that we did it with Steve Aoki conserve
was in an audience now I'm remembering
it wrong it wasn't an audience it was
just at the show people were walking by
but they did stop and they did watch us
but I think this is going to be
different than that work we might be on
the stage and stuff so it is going to be
like a level of tired that
before so now I'm sorry to get nervous I
wasn't nervous before this dang it Pat
how many do you think are gonna show up
I don't know La La's are different
people out yeah that's us competing with
like I feel I left Jon Snow panel I go
to the John Scalzi
oh [ __ ] and I think max I'm really
looking forward to the moment when I say
whenever we want and see if anyone else
follows in the crowd
I'm not she's scared cuz I feel like
we're all gonna talk about with each
other as if there is an audience and one
gets type right yeah so now there's like
60 I'll talk all the time yeah but yes
I've been to comic-con before it was
pretty awesome
and I've been to Anime Expo I've been to
comic-con I've been to all these
different like Expos and I always love
coming here because people have really
dull costumes and the time that they
take to make it all legit I think I can
appreciate that art it's pretty awesome
I have personally been to the San Diego
Comic Cons I feel like I'm free music
and then we've had for about behaviour
yeah we've got a bunch of conventions
but my first time at a Comic Con
my favorite comment
well I'm a marble girls love like our
families and marble family but about
have to pick up favorite and theme
oh my gosh I'm blinking under name
pressure scriber powers and stuff take
it
it's illiterate I think her name is
literally warped Captain Marvel oh my
god now the nerves are really picking it
and now I'm gonna brain fart
dang it no okay I'm gonna I'm gonna do
good yes Captain Marvel is my favorite
comic book character oh wait hold on I
gotta think about this tomorrow I do
like comic [ __ ] like I literally
just referred to a grand slam as any
zealand you had to tell me that it was
for baseball
he's John snow in any game around town
my favorite oh [ __ ] man don't even tell
ok I think my favorite right now is
dentists of course movies because he got
ADHD like me I'm gonna go with you can
swim and I admire Jason Momoa - my hero
is my mom I'm just kidding
Wolverine give me a little break and I'm
down to look at that I think I just did
yours you got nervous you did won't
bring my hand down favorite superhero of
all time
[ __ ] badass he heals like me I like
asleep he likes to work out customer
nice to work out ferocious like being
ferocious and he's introverted like me
are you Brosius than your little spoon
very approaches
sayonara it's a sayonara sayonara
sayonara stupid
[Applause]
you ought to be this is the middle hey
guys what's up so we're gonna do an off
the record for you guys yeah you're
ready let's do it we're gonna talk about
whatever
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the live off the record was [ __ ]
awesome because I tested the fans to see
how ng I can go and then we were talking
about four we were talking about all
this stuff I think it was pretty awesome
to be able to create like on the spot
like the different types of ideas and
comedy that we do like how people can
witness how JK news is being created
live without the editing and we just
made up a joke like about like doing a
movie following a porn star like it's a
rocky movie like like a porn star
becomes like a rags to riches story of a
porn star
it was really funny so you gotta watch
it for that I can't recap some
compensation
Wow to me the funniest one was right
there's no one for DP best best double
penetration for those of you and she got
on stage and she was like I just want to
thank my dad because he like stepsister
and now I do porn and thanks for
watching me take tix and then she
accepted speech I've ever
because og are now like that like it's a
[ __ ] yeah yeah hey what's your
favorite uh ter okay my favorite
conversation in the off the record I
like just five most the audience it's
really fun to ask them questions and try
to incorporate them into the
conversation that's how I always feel
when we have a guest on to and they're
not talking much it's weird to do
something but we'll all engage the
conversation and not bringing the people
who aren't talking in so it was fun to
try to bring them into it so that it was
more of like we're all talking together
we're all talking around here the whole
time I was up there I was so nervous
I was kind of like floating so was it
really registering what was happening
but I think it was I guess the part that
I remember being involved in was talk
about video games that was really fun
talking about how Isaac teabags Casey in
the video game but yeah I had a great
time though it was really fun is just I
was I was really nervous I didn't
realize how nervous I was until I
pointed out how nervous I was
and then that's when I got really
oh I really like that we're getting an
immediate like feedback from stuff that
we say and liver like just sitting there
they were like asking questions directly
to us like this we're saying is sorry
they were like oh what else did he say
and I'm like oh [ __ ] vicodin fireless
went a steep open-top
right in the beginning of suggests in
general about the relationship
we went overtime on our meeting we're
only supposed to be there for an hour
but I was like you know what let's let
everyone in it was kind of surprising
but also pretty cool it made me so happy
I was like let's just meet every single
person that came to see us I thought it
was really cool that there's so many
people that support Margo
a lot of times they don't really know
the comments and the views and stuff but
to see all these people like
we thing that we do like a guy will wear
barbell but also five shady agents and
also called I love short daddy
wow that's so cool they did we were
supporting like everything that we
and I love how many people were like
recycle recycle recycle my man I
should've brought him that was really
cute all the fans were really doble a
lot of them like didn't even know JK was
going to be here and they were kind of
on the fence about coming to come and
then they were like oh
you see a lot of like written words and
comments but we never get to see like
the faces my first comic-con
I thought I was really cause exactly
what I expected like people with like
the sickest costumes
going around I do with some people had a
little more confidence in their costumes
I saw guys and phantoms outfit and
Benham is like a monstrous [ __ ]
but this High School
it was just really funny to see like a
ferocious Robocop start walking robot
well this guy Freddy Krueger's behind us
and he was lost
he's only gonna see PS again I do that
like zombies
okay in closing I just want to say if
you feel awkward meeting all of us in
person or whatever don't because these
[ __ ] feel way more awkward to
get into the cut of this real quick look
at how weirdly they're all standing
we're in the middle of [ __ ] comic-con
absolutely so much going on around you
and they're all like so if you feel that
way just know that these guys are too
and we're all the same
[Music]